a nondescript building in rural
Oxfordshire a new an unlikely
battlefront against covert 19 we've been
given exclusive access to public health
England's contact tracing nerve center
for South England so we might identify
three or four people in that setting
that we have Trish Manus is an
epidemiologist with more than 20 years
experience of stopping the spread of
infectious diseases her team's work was
critical in slowing the spread of covert
19 when the first clusters were
discovered in Brighton there are methods
to find people you may have been in
contact with an example is I went to the
gym last night I was there for an hour I
don't know any of the people that I was
within two meters of but we can go back
to the gym and ask them who was
exercising in that class and they can
help us identify those people but now as
we look towards an easing of
restrictions contact tracers will take
the lead in preventing a second wave the
focus is about bringing the reproductive
number below one and so they are not or
the reproductive number must say below
one if we're going to contain this
contact tracing allows those social
distancing measures to be relaxed so
that we can minimize the spread from
anyone who has a disease
the data collected by the covert 19
tracing app launched here on the Isle of
Wight will be used by contact tracers to
identify and stop potential outbreaks
new technology working in tandem with
traditional infection control methods
the work has been relentless and
exhausting and there's no sign of it
easing up
it's very intense for the individuals
doing the interviews but of course it's
really intense for the people on the
other side of the interview they're
obviously feeling concerned about who
they may have transmitted this to very
guilty particularly very early on
have you felt overwhelmed at any stage
it's a it's a good question I think I've
always felt challenged and I suspect
there are challenges to come it's very
very difficult working in a new emerging
field with new emerging science with a
scale that we don't recognize the work
being done by Trish manners and her
teams can't be understated simply it
will help to stop more people dying to
start living again Joshi Sky News